make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking up with Empire number zero
those you guys know no Empire is like
the big event that Marvel is doing or at
least one of them they're also doing
like an x-men centric event but Empire
is kind of a big one now in the midst of
everything that's been going on it's
kind of flown under the radar right not
a whole lot of advertising going on
because there's no real comics coming
out and as we know how many book
companies don't really advertise on TV
um this this whole cenar this this whole
thing is cool right because this is kind
of my bread and butter right this this
this whole situation this in terms of
the history and the story that's being
told right so this initially picks up
with the slaughter of the Cotati by the
the entire Cotati race is being
massacred here and it's kind of wild
right in terms of them just being being
killed in such a a brutal way right the
garden on the moon is kind of how its
referred to you now the reality is that
all this is really Tony Stark kind of
waking up from a dream and there's a
couple different things going on here
the first is that Tony Stark recalls
that this is basically how the
kree-skrull war started insofar as it
was told to him during the events of the
kree-skrull war but the other thing to
understand here is kind of what's not
shown like what's what's not explicitly
stated here so the way that's played out
for those you guys who were curious the
reason why the Cotati mattered and the
reason why it's kind of important is
because in the early days not really
even the early days of Earth but like
millions of years ago right ah the the
scroll race was basically a peaceful
race now they had gone through all kinds
of crazy situations right they've gone
through all kinds of different scenarios
and so on you had the Celestials
experimenting on them different things
like that but uh but the way though the
way that played out to kind of a give
you a brief little history they're like
you had to scroll as a race they were
met by the arrival of the Celestials in
the same way that earth was you know
thirty thousand years ago but for them
it was much longer before the Celestials
broke their race into thirds they
experimented on them you got the the
deviants you got the Eternals and then
you got the baseline scrolls you also
got the dire wraiths but that's a whole
different kettle of beans but Dyer rates
are amazing they were just like this
force of destruction across the universe
but the idea here was that unlike earth
where we ended up seeing that the
deviants were ultimately not really
annihilated was certainly pushed to the
brink of extinction by the Celestials at
a future point in time the deviants
actually ended up coming out on top in
the scroll homeworld right so basically
all the eternal Scrolls and for the most
part the baseline scrolls were
essentially wiped out and the deviant
scrolls were the ones who reign supreme
now after generations eventually the the
deviant Scrolls found their inner peace
basic
and then they started charting the
spaceways and that led to them creating
this massively expansive Empire now in
an effort to expand their empire and to
bring other races in they traveled to
the homeworld of Halle and Halle at the
time was occupied by as most of you guys
know the Kree but also occupied by the
cotati
and they go tidier basically like brute
except they have leaves right that's
really the only difference between them
but what ended up happening is the
scrolls took a 'he's a segment of each
population and then created the blue
area of the moon now the blue area of
the moon is a section of the moon where
it has oxygen and they were dropped off
there and the idea was that they were
told basically you have one year to use
whatever resources you can find here to
build something and then when we come
back we will judge your creations and
determine whether or not you're suitable
to be part of the Skrull homeworld oh
and also only one of you can join this
led to the one-year period passing the
the scrolls returned and when they did
they found that like the Kree had built
some kind of big Citadel or something
like that right some big gaudy fancy
monstrosity and the Cotati had built
this lush jungle well because the the
scrolls were peaceful they sided with
the Cotati the Kree were pissed they
ended up killing all the Cotati on the
moon they killed the entire scroll
delegation which I believed included the
King three reverse-engineer the
technology flew back to holla
and then basically started building
their own warships and wiped out all the
cotati anjala at the same time or at
least most of them and then because the
fact that they killed the scroll King
this led to the beginning of the crease
for a war right and it's been waging on
for millions of years right it really is
just kinda like a blood feud in a lot of
ways
ah but that's really what's what's what
this whole preview segment is right now
the reason why that matters and the
reason that's important is because
around the time of Tony Stark wakes up
he's suddenly met by a message from
Carol Danvers right who basically says
we have a kind of SOS on the moon we
need to go over there and figure out
what's going on right so the Avengers
end up hopping aboard one of their ships
they travel out there to the moon one of
the other things I'll kind of want to
point out here is Thor we can largely
assume that this story takes place after
the the beginning or at least that the
first arc of Thor but we can also kind
of assume it takes place before right
because as we know Thor is essentially
the king of Asgard and so it seems like
he'll most likely as that role he would
stay on Asgard which is kind of what
he'd been doing as opposed to leaving it
so I think it takes place after the
first arc or the one where he becomes a
Herald of Galactus
we're gonna largely assume it takes
place after that this is one of those
murky situations that we see from time
to time is one of the issues that you
have when you have a solo book involving
a character and what's going on doesn't
seemed to match up with a team but
muffles been doing this for years but
it's one of the things you just kind of
run into it doesn't really matter it's
just thor's there but you also have like
Panther you've got she-hulk he got
Captain America Steve Rogers you got a
few things going on but when they
arrived there they end up finding out -
this blue area of the moon has basically
been developed by the cotati now you'll
also notice that the entire Citadel of
The Watcher is basically gone or kind of
you know covered in your plant life and
so on remember The Watcher who wants you
he's been dead ever since original sin
right he's been dead for a long time so
his whole space station in an area is
kind of abandoned Marvel will bring him
back eventually right and everything
will kind of go back to the way that it
used to be but but in the interim he's
gone right so the whole place is its I
guess is basically squatter's rights is
really what it amounts to you at this
point in time but when he arrived there
Captain America immediately picks up on
something that he's been in all
different kinds of jungles across earth
and in this jungle there's no signs of
life right there there's no insects
weather there's no bugs there's no no
animals no nothing it's just a jungle
with absolutely no signs of life and the
blue area of the moon can't sustain that
life so right off the bat you know
Captain America knows it's not an
earth-based experiment right it's not
like some kind of Earth experiment that
was going on there was happening at the
hands of like rocks on oil and somehow
went bad or something along those lines
but in the midst of all that there's
suddenly met by the arrival of a Kree
century now the Kree centuries were cool
back in the day they were pretty
interesting Marvel hasn't used them in
years in fact I think the last time they
had any real role in Marvel Comics was
during anihilation conquest after that
they just kind of up here every once in
a while but the Kree centuries were
designed for the purpose of basically
fighting in the stead of priests
soldiers if necessary and if unnecessary
basically just bolstering their forces
right that was the idea behind it and
that's what you've got with the Kree
centuries right these things were
powerful enough to take down an entire
army right I mean they're they're crazy
right you said one Kree sentry on earth
it would obliterate most of the heroes
on earth now people like Thor other
people out there you know Incredible
Hulk who are exceedingly strong and
could physically subdue a Kree sentry
they'll do fine but like 90% of the
earth superheroes would fall but it
basically takes the combined forces of
the Avengers to hold off as best they
can
right there's not really outright
defending it it's just doing the best
they can to take it out and then
suddenly they're met by the arrival of
some mysterious guy who chops off the
head of the Kree sentry this kind of
plant-based head more or less and then
basically tells the Avengers to attack
they do they finish the job and the Kree
centuries destroyed
then the question becomes who in the
heck is this guy and then suddenly Thor
immediately recognizes who this guy is
right that he was an old Avenger in old
school Avenger and that he's basically a
guy that for welcomes now this is not
one of these scenarios where Marvel's
introducing a new character and we had
just never seen him before we've seen
this guy before
this is swordsman or at least kind of
swordsman but not will swordsman back in
the day he sucked right I mean he wasn't
very interesting at all he was kind of
crappy he was a guy who basically I
think I think he gained a lot of his
skills from like circus acts and so on
and so forth he was an insanely talented
Acrobat he trained Hawkeye different
things like that it's one of these
things where he basically got too big
for his britches he was sent into the
Avengers to basically become a mole and
he ended up falling in love with Scarlet
Witch and then something else ended up
happening but he ended up basically
defying his mission and then was killed
in the process and the reason why this
matters is because what the coach hottie
managed to do it was basically resurrect
him now this is the danger of what's
going on in Marvel Comics right now when
Jonathan Hickman launched the x-men and
Jonathan Hickman came up with this idea
of having the five lights or the five
whatever you want to call them who can
serve the purpose of resurrecting old
x-men Hickman did it in a way where it
was very controlled right it's very much
like like it has to have a purpose and
it has to have a reason for why that
person is coming back swordsmen sucks
nobody ever wanted swords gonna come
back there's nobody there's nobody out
there in the history of Marvel Comics
who ever sat down and said man you know
who I want to see come back swordsman I
want to see Jacques du Keane there would
have higher higher pronounce his name I
want to see him come back because he was
just so cool like nobody said that and
that's kind of the issue David that you
run into resurrecting people for the
sake of a story now it could just be
this as a one-off this is all we get
with this issue number zero it's way too
early to tell right it's much too early
to be a naysayer but it is a little bit
of a concern but the overall gist is
that you end up having a swordsman who
basically you know reveals that he ended
up having a child essentially with with
mantis that child is basically Sequoia
but ultimately Sequoia was introduced as
basically the the son of mantis and kind
of a coach hottie hybrid we didn't
really know the significance of his
character but what's being done now is
basically saying that this guy is kind
of a spiritual leader of the cotati
and that he will ultimately lead the
universe into a place where he's going
to get rid of all evil right which is
somewhat of a bold statement now this
comic is basically narrated by
iron man and when he hears that his
whole thought is like that's kind of a
crazy scenario right that's kind of a
crazy thing but seemingly there hadn't
really been a coronation of sorts we're
kind of baptism of sorts to verify that
that Sequoia is recognized in this
capacity this that kind of seems to be
the case and so for using his ability to
control the weather because the fact
that there is oxygen here oxygen in turn
means it means an atmosphere which means
whether Thor uses his ability in order
to create a kind of coronation event
more or less and then basically baptizes
this kid you know to kind of fit he's
stepping into manhood more or less it's
kind of the case right because when Thor
knew him and when Thor you know helped
this kid he was a teenager right so you
know now there's kind of an adult's not
really a kid it's kind of a coronation
basically saying like you know this is
sort of a recognition of your power and
your role and everything going on and
then we finally get an explanation of
what the heck is going on and the big
concern here is that if the Cotati are
bad then why haven't the Kree attacked
right because the Kree will have kind of
like this vendetta against the cotati
they hate them right they kill them
everywhere they can find them even the
ones who escape and the explanation
that's given here is that you know the
the century that was that was fought
against by the Avengers is a-- is half
scroll in half creek well then that begs
the question why do we have a half
scroll and half Kree century running
around and the answer is that the Kree
and the scroll not have an alliance this
race that's been fighting each other for
millions of years are now a lot in a
singular cost now if you've been reading
Marvel cosmic really since 2006 right
since since annihilation and even if you
go back and read the old kree-skrull war
by the way Thomas this is horrifying
right because what you have are two of
the most powerful empires in the
entirety of Marvel Comics a lying
themselves right so it's like who could
possibly stand against them it would be
like if Galactus and Thanos you know
joined forces for the purpose of just
like eradicating life right like like
you know let's not even say that right
because it's a little one-sided when you
talk about that let's say fan us with
the Infinity Gauntlet and the marquee of
death right like if they allied with
each other to like annihilate life
across the cosmos across the multiverse
who's gonna stop them right like
nobody's gonna stop them and that's
really kind of what this shows it's like
they've combined their forces they
basically combine their their their
entire armadas right so their entire
fleets are brought together so you're
talking about this colossal war machine
formed by the two biggest and probably
most dangerous empires in the entirety
of Marvel Comics
big deal right because then the question
starts being asked okay like how do we
respond to this right now carol danvers
has stepped away as the leader of Alpha
Flight and Abigail brand has taken her
place that most likely happened because
of the fact that that's what's gonna
happen in the MCU that that basically
Carol Danvers was gonna move away she's
not really gonna be the leader of Alpha
Flight she's gonna be when these people
he kind of travels in the space and
whatever happens happens or maybe she
just stays on earth as an Avenger but
Abigail brand is gonna be introduced and
that makes sense right Joss Whedon
introduced her during his astonishing
x-men run the MCU usually kind of goes
with the the traditional origins of
concepts and then modifies them later on
down the road so that sort of makes
sense what's going on Plus Abigail Bram
was a more effective leader of alpha
fighters sword right she had the ability
to speak every language in existence
right so it kind of made sense that
she's gonna be a liaison for aliens out
there because she can translate
understand their languages and so on but
the big fear here is that if the Kree in
the scroll are or a lying themselves and
they're in turn heading for the moon
then are they going to head to earth not
only that I a man kind of looks at this
and says they're gonna head for the
Cotati
right they're gonna wipe out the entire
Cotati race and that's what Sequoia says
their goal here is to kill us the Kree
hate us because it's the Kree and they
hate us and the the scrolls hate us
because they see us as their great error
have they not done what they did you
know all these lives that would have
been lost over the years would never
have been lost in the first place and so
as we also they say they've kind of
allied the Avengers basically come
together at least the Avengers team as
it exists now and the response of Iron
Man is we will do whatever it takes to
basically save the Cotati now I'm gonna
tell you guys right now not a chance
this ragtag band of Avengers despite how
high-profile they are are going to stand
a chance to take out the entire Kree and
the scroll arm on it that's not gonna
happen right that's never going to
happen there's no possible chance that
anybody with any rational mind would
look at this and say they definitely
could do that right like hundreds of
thousands of ships they could definitely
take them out not a chance
but the idea of Iron Man is we're going
to pull together and we're gonna pull
this off so this indicates we're gonna
get a lot more characters involved here
and that's of course where the empire of
an expanse but where he also makes the
comment we don't care who it is that
gets in our way what we end up finding
out or at least the way it appears that
part of this Armada that's basically
been formed here has been formed by the
Fantastic Four but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
like and I will catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]